Chelsea Clinton is in a little bit of
hot water because she made a remark
about an issue which is a little a
little religious yes the problem yeah
well for answers were joined by New York
Times bestselling author the wheel
Wilder Series Fox News contributor
Raymond Arroyo Raymond's Chelsea was on
sirius XM radio today made some alarming
remarks what's going on yes she did
listen to this Lord this is a town hall
meeting a left-of-center one
she's clearly setting herself up for a
political run watch when I think about
all of the statistics that are are
painful of what women are confronting
Zerlina today in our country and what
even more women confronted pre row we
just can't go back to that I think
that's unconscionable to me and also and
I'm sure that this will unleash another
wave of hate in my direction but as a
deeply religious person it's also
unchristian do me
so it's unchristian to stop people from
having abortions now look no matter
where you stand on this issue and it is
a deeply hurtful issue for a lot of
people and a wrenching one to suggest
that people who defend life are somehow
acting in an unchristian manner the game
and women who through their religion
believe their religion compels them to
protect innocent life this is these are
remarks that I think people are gonna
unleash hate no it it unleashes hate its
disbelief like you could disagree about
this issue but it's almost you're
questioning the Christian beliefs of
those who believe it's right to protect
the most vulnerable right and you
remember you'll remember a month ago she
said abortion actually contributed three
point five trillion dollars to the
economy because all those the mothers
then went into the workplace because
they were free if a million what about
these they weren't born right who
weren't contributing to the economy it
all of this reminded me of Nancy Pelosi
who you remember the theologian in 2008
had this to say what is an ardent
practicing Catholic this is an issue
that I had studied for a long
and what I know is over the centuries
the doctors of the church have not been
able to make that definition and senator
uh sunson st. Augustine said at three
months you don't know Saint Agustin
considered abortion evil violence and
said it was deeply immoral so Nancy
Pelosi I mean she's many things she can
whip up votes theologian I ever st.
Thomas Aquinas because Nancy Pelosi
Laura as you know les Moonves was
ejected from CBS after six more women
came forward accusing him of abuse and
the CBS Board is investigating to see
how big of a severance package he'll get
now his wife Julie Chen appeared finally
on Big Brother a show she has hosted for
18 years here she is last night as she
closed out the hour watch I'm Julie Chen
Moonves goodnight the first time she has
ever identified as Julie chin Moonves as
a sign of support for her husband I
thought les was gonna pop out of that
door phone well had the class that the
cameras of Big Brother been in the CBS
hallways we might you know really the
finale well that was the finale of that
for the season but other women at CBS
from dais pastor now coming forward like
Linda bloodworth-thomason who was
responsible for designing women she has
a harrowing account where she says he
ended her career and killed many shows
with women in the lead she wrote one
thing in the hollywood reported this is
kind of terrifying of a major actress
she said coming off the cancellation of
her iconic detective show the star began
pitching a new one he informed her that
she was too old to be on the network she
began to cry and stood up to go he stood
up took her by the shoulders telling her
I can't let you leave like this she
reacted suddenly touched then he shoved
his tongue down her throat I know this
happened because the star is the person
who told me it is believed that that
star is probably Angela Lansbury who was
getting 40 million viewers a week when
her show was canceled and every Thomson
good friends where Clinton's remember
right friends as well
now designing women is coming back so is
Murphy Brown but there's one reboot that
I can promise you Les Moonves will not
want to see again
and I think she it'll be a murder she
does if Lansbury comes back and it'll be
Les Moonves on the other end of that one
so he won't we won't be seeing that
reboot
Julie Julie Chen Moonves EE Chen